[Music]
spring gives way to summer and summer
gives way to fall now that we're
starting at the midway point of the four
anime season it's just apt for me to ask
this question how has fall been treating
you have you been enjoying this season's
offers and more well we can put those
aside momentarily as we look a bit ahead
to the winter season now because the
ride never stops for an anime fan and as
soon as the season winds down and we
bait our favorite shows our emotional
goodbyes a new batch will take their
place and give us something to look
forward to and given the lineup that we
have today winter 2021 shaping up to be
won blockbuster season so stay strong
don't lose hope and let's see what the
next anime season has prepared for us
we start off with rusty tabisco now
here's a fresh take on the
post-apocalyptic setting we've all heard
of those natural disasters and alien
invasions but what if the phenomenon
that would turn japan into a barren
wasteland was something called rusty
wind thanks to rusty wind allegedly
brought about by mushroom spores the
world's been left in tatters and the
spotlight falls on wanted criminal bisco
akaboshi bisco traverses the wastelands
of japan in search of the legendary
mushroom that could put an end to the
rust that's for too long cursed the
earth now this is a pretty strange
premise that would raise eyebrows but
that's just what makes anime so amazing
you can take a wild premise like this
and come up with award-winning light
novels out of it it looks like one of
those surreal and super fun shows from
the trailer alone and while i wouldn't
be rushing to pen this as my new anime
of the season contender just yet it
seems to have the traits that could make
it a mainstream hit
[Applause]
ninth on the list is orient it's not
quite muggy but odaka shinobu's next
work after finishing that adventure
manga of hers takes us to a somewhat
familiar territory orient also takes us
to a fantasy world of the supernatural
and this time it stars a new tandem of
good friends musashi and kojiro they set
forth on demon slaying quests as samurai
aspirants but unfortunately for them the
world's changed since and demons have
become the pillars of society after
saving musashi from a near-death
experience gojiro decides to re-pursue
their old dream and return to the world
of beast slaying with one goal fix the
tarnish reputation of the samurai while
ridding the world of demons after
enjoying the hell out of maggie i really
look forward to what otaka has up her
sleeve with this new series if you're
craving for a supernatural adventure
series with a lot of action then this
one will be for you
[Music]
this whole thing with irregular really
reminds me of index a few years prior a
franchise seemed to be dead in the water
suddenly getting a revival and all of a
sudden these new seasons and spinoffs
keep popping up one after another we
just had the second season and honor
spin-off and it's now time to head back
to the story with the much-anticipated
reminiscence arc the sheba siblings
backstory and their long family history
have been on the minds of lots of fans
and it's finally time to see that very
important chapter animated all shall be
revealed and you'll finally see the
siblings connections with the powerful
yotsuba family and how mayuki got her
signature admiration for her brother
it's a shame that a lot of the backstory
arcs for popular light novels never see
the light of deus anime due to their
placements but irregulars are popular
enough franchise to get this benefit
fans of the franchise will love this new
character-centric arc to further develop
the irregular at magic high school
universe
ever wondered why it took this long to
have an anime about cosplay in dolls
yeah me neither when we consider the big
mainstream ones well you're in luck as
my dress-up darling looks to take the
rom-com genre to what seems to be
uncharted territory my dress-up darling
is an anime featuring an outgoing and
stylish girl meeting her polar opposite
in this case an easily flustered guy
who's into dolls and clothes make him
now that's quite a strange combination
right off the bat but having read some
of the manga i'd say that the pairing
works a lot better than it should do at
first glance a simple plot some great
chemistry between leads and lots of edgy
should make this one of the niche
favorites this season it probably won't
go down as a series that's going to be
remembered but it's one that will surely
lighten up your day i found the manga
irresistible so i wonder if the anime is
going to be able to relay those same
feelings when i do watch it
they say all publicity is good publicity
and there's no further proof of it than
ari furetha you remember how much people
hated this thing on the internet mostly
due to how it was adapted the ps1 tier
cgi and just plain old isakai tiredness
well guess what it's also one of the
most popular shows being streamed back
in its season and it's getting a second
season likely thanks to all of that
publicity fingers crossed that it will
get better this time though especially
in the animation department after all
we've got a pretty tight adventure ahead
as hajime continues his conquest through
the world's labyrinth bringing along
with him his ever-growing set of female
companions hajime's thirst for revenge
may have been partially quenched but the
constant adventure of uncovering the
truth behind the fantasy world continues
intriguing arcs like a heart-stopping
adventure inside a volcano awaits you in
the second season of ari furetha and if
you're a fan of the series like i am
you'll no doubt be excited to see the
overpowered hajime and the gang make
their return before we move on to the
next entry i'd like to take a break and
ask for your subscriptions a lot of
viewers still aren't subscribed to the
channel so if you do fall into that
category and you've been having a great
time so far please make sure you click
that subscribe button and ring the bell
it really helps my channel grow and i'll
be really happy to hit that next major
milestone with your help right then
let's get back to the show
next up is tribe9 and it's going to be a
super unhinged sports anime it comes
with designs that look straight out of
danganronpa which we'll get into in a
bit with how much the japanese love
baseball i'm pretty surprised that we
don't actually have too many anime about
the sport at least those that recently
received mainstream attention well
perhaps baseball with a twist is gonna
do the trick when the two main
characters with completely different
backgrounds meet up with the strongest
extreme baseball player they get
themselves thrust head first into the
world of tribes battling it out for
supremacy all over neo tokyo it's got
sports it's got a sleek sci-fi look this
thing looks promising and if you liked
uncle dharma drive and dun gun romper
tribe 9 could be something right up your
alley the vibes are the same and the
three shows share the same creator this
seems to be one of those over-the-top
sports madness shows and if you're
looking for something to get hyped on
tribe 9's showing quite a lot of promise
49 is the third season of takagi-san now
i didn't expect this honestly speaking i
just can't get enough of takagi and
nishikata's antics and even the side
characters are all super entertaining as
well so it was such a pleasure to get
the news of a third season and an
upcoming movie what makes the news so
much sweeter is how the third season
will be coming as early as winter if you
watch something like nagatoro or
uzakijan you should know what to expect
out of this show school shenanigans
between a girl and the guy she likes
that she constantly teases among those
three i feel that takagi has the most
playful and cutest way of going at it
which is a big plus it's just a sweet
charming show that you can turn on and
relax with after a tiring day it's a
slice of life so you can just hop in and
enjoy the third season this winter but i
would highly recommend watching the
first two seasons as well
in third place we take a look at requiem
of the rose king when i first saw this
title i wasn't quite sure what to make
of it the title alone quickly gives you
some impression of what it's going to be
about and in terms of setting i found my
predictions to be quite right it's a
story that takes us back to middle age
europe where civil wars called the war
of roses have ravaged the land richard's
been reviled ever since birth a cursed
child if you may taking on both male and
female characteristics the child grew up
in a life defined by hatred salvation is
at hand though if only richard can help
his father become king in spite of the
sneers and the enemies including the
famed joan of arc and his own mother
will this child bring glory to england
or sink it further into the abyss yes if
you've guessed it by now this is a manga
take on the classic shakespeare play
richard iii it has all the darkness
you'd expect out of shakespeare
accompanied by scandals betrayals and
some rather unsettling themes this is
certainly meant for someone who's into
something like pandora hearts in terms
of aesthetic which is quite ironic
considering the next entry on our list
[Music]
before the previous season started i had
high hopes for vanitas i'm more than
happy to see that the hopes weren't
misplaced the show got quite a following
and despite not getting as much
mainstream traction as i would have
hoped vanitas first season met all my
high expectations i mean it's not easy
to get something as intricate and so
unique in its atmosphere and feel as
vanitas right but those guys at bones
did it they freaking did it i expect the
team to bring the same energy they had
for the second season and i sure hope
they get some of the key moments right i
won't spoil you too much about the
content of the second season but just
let me say that if you're a big fan of g
you're gonna be in for a treat i hope
that you can give vanitas a shot it's
got quite the unique ambiance that you
won't typically get from modern anime
and i think that the anime so far is
something that everyone can enjoy our
most anticipated anime for winter is
soccer attack on titan's final season
yeah okay everyone saw it coming didn't
they but there's no denying it attack on
titan is an anime that's defined an
entire generation of fans and it's a
no-brainer that its grand finale is our
most anticipated anime of winter 2021.
it's been a wild roller coaster of
emotions throughout the years from the
hot-blooded fights gripping revelations
and the dramatic storyline twists and
turns attack on titan has taken us all
on an amazing ride and i'm both so sad
and excited to see that it's all finally
coming to an end this winter now all
that's left to see is if the anime will
bring enough justice to the exciting
manga finale that had the entire world
talking but given how well and how much
respect attack on titan gets as an
adaptation i expect nothing but
greatness see the hottest anime
phenomenon come to its ultimate
conclusion only this winter 2021 i don't
think there's any doubt that attack on
titan's final season is what most people
are watching out for but what do you
think what are some of the shows that
you're personally looking forward to
this coming winter season i'd love to
know your thoughts on this so do put
them down in the comment section below i
hope you had fun with this video and
don't forget to like and subscribe if
you did have a great time you can also
check out vinnie tube on instagram as
well as give your support through my
patreon and channel memberships i'll see
you next time take care and wishing you
the best
[Music]
you